oh good oils portable food mason jars
guys let's be real the Millennials
well people hate them and I do too and
I'm one of them but they do have one
thing going for them and that is the
fact that they have brought mason jars
to the forefront
oh yes folks we are moving beyond the
mason jar salad and bringing you three
amazing mason jar soups here that are
perfect for bringing to work because
they are portable they are sustainable
and most importantly they are totally
Instagram Abal and my three recipes are
both vegan and gluten free so they are
super awesome for getting back on track
this January ok guys I'm super excited
to get this let's do this first up my
miso noodle soup my mason jar i layer
some sliced mushrooms red bell peppers
some shredded bok choy some extra firm
tofu some shredded carrots some cooked
SOPA noodles a vegetable bullion miso
paste sesame oil gluten free tamari and
some sriracha then when I'm ready to eat
I just add my boiling water give it a
good stir and enjoy
next up my Italian pasta soup to my
mason jar I add some chopped zucchini
some cooked gluten-free pasta some
chopped green beans some white beans
some chopped spinach chopped basil
tomato sauce some chili flakes and some
vegetable bullion
then I add my boiling water and enjoy
and finally my kick pea beet soup
twende sinjar I add some chopped
zucchini grated beets some chickpeas
diced tomato chopped parsley and some
vegetable bullion zatar lemon juice salt
pepper pepitas when ready to eat I add
my boiling water and enjoy
so guys there you have it three amazing
vegan and gluten-free mason jar soups
that you are going to love and all of
your coworkers are gonna be super
jealous of so guys I hope you enjoyed
this video if you did be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
with some of your favorite soup flavors
I will totally try to incorporate them
into a mason jar soup recipe subscribe
to the channel and I will see you next
time on Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]